hello everybody my name is markip and
welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's
there's a there's a couple here that I
absolutely have not done any of which is
like food prep at L chips and the other
one so I'm going to try those first see
how they play out complete the orders on
time it's like that drink one hello
what the
freak is that just me or is anyone else
seeing things moving in the Darkness I
know I'm looking at just pure Darkness
right now and it may not seem like much
I don't know if the YouTube compression
is going to be able to Showcase anything
but like maybe I'm crazy but something
was weird
there all right oh I didn't read oh wow
I know what to do make food that's all
ah sod pops goop a
gun oh welcome to your new career and
Food Service it is a task so simple a
human can do it pay attention I am only
going to say this
once step one you will receive an order
which tells you what food to prepare
step two make that
food step three place the food on the
serving tray do not forget the size and
drinks step four ring the bell when the
food is ready to be delivered to a
hungry
guest receive a new order and the cycle
repeats for the rest of your life or
until you get old and are replaced by
someone Young hunger get the orders
right or you will be severely
recomended you have been adequately
trained now prepare for the dinner rush
okay um thank oh where'd you go thank
you for
that
oh is that an
order you said dinner rush that's a
morning Rush hi what can I uh corn yep
you got it corn coming
up put that on oh
probably that yeah that's probably how I
do corn and Fazbear
fla 153 you got it don't worry I got you
Wham order up thank you very much have a
lovely day this ain't so
bad all right what do you want corn you
got it corn always good to start the day
off right Fazbear fla 525 don't know why
all these have different microwave
settings but there you have it order
up this is nice morning rush just two
people business is not
booming business is the opp noon
Rush noon
Rush hey what's up how you doing pink
lemonade oh yeah you got it pink
lemonade coming up
hello all right pink lemonade roxxy's
nachos with nacho cheese all right Roxy
nachos with nacho cheese going going to
get you blasted Don't You Worry About a
Thing hold on let me blast you there
there you go
wait hold on put that there put that
there and Order up get out of here get
out of here come on in come on in yeah I
know I know I know you are not
done sour lime chica skinny Taco you got
it buom bum bum nope two
5 with
guac how do I get this to there we go
guac squaa guac and
Bam well what what chica skinny Taco 51
two with a blast of guac okay
guac there's there's that with a blast
of guac and then sour lime that's sour
lime right I am waiting I don't care
what you're doing
you think you're the only one not under
pressure get out of
here you think you can just yell at me
huh I know that's your friend over there
oh you want to give me some sass I'm
loaded up to my tits and potatoes here
and you're doing nothing but carrying
food why don't you shove it up your Gob
take a blast of that and shut up H if
you want to get some freaking food why
don't you come back behind the counter
and get it yourself I don't see you
helping
anybody have a lovely day oh wow
afternoon Rush that's definitely a time
that I remember in my food service days
hi welcome yes come on in you're going
to want an orange I see okay orange corn
that timer is not is way too much okay
Fazbear flond with guac that's
weird but what do I question come on how
do you one hand this dumb thing you want
guac take guac and then here's your dum
dumb drink have a good day get out of
here yeah how am I supposed to do this
in that time okay sodon that sounds
strange Fazbear fla at a 213 put that
there you're going to need that there
got hot sauce on the
fla and then you got what do you got
rocking nachos add a 313 put that on
there you want some hot sauce and you
want nacho cheese of course you do there
you go order up come back never what you
drink what you poison corn a that's
that's surprising what did you say to me
what did you say you want some beans
I'll stick some beans in you all right
just fla okay no customizations I can
appreciate that and you can appreciate
this get out of here you Dro your fla
that is legally
servable that is legally what who's
talking to me oh
evening Rush yeah they don't have
regular meals here you got
drink oh no you got corn you got corn of
course you do there's corn there's rice
that's going way too fast I don't know
what that's about that doesn't seem
right all right you got this at a
215 you're going to have a blast of guac
I know and hot sauce here get out of
here T you got a drink what do you want
drink what your poison want the cleaning
sour lime of course a robot of taste
with a skinny Taco at a two nope okay
damn
it okay skinny tacos there sour lime is
there you have a
Nachos it is not rocket science oh my
God shut up it's pressing buttons not
what I want it to do shut up what do you
want want hot sauce on this and then
what else nacho cheese on this got it
get out of here what do you mean you
slow what do you mean that's what it was
that's literally what it was you're the
one that told me what you wanted why do
I have to do anything for
you you could basically just do this
yourself I don't know why that I got to
do it all for you you you want nachos
because I did get the nachos they were
done right you want not you want blam
did I get that backwards or something
that's correct now leave you dropped
your soda and I don't
care all right we got beans oh my God if
you can get off my counter you will be
served immensely
immediately you know this doesn't help
me and definitely is going to help you
when I beat the out of you
so nacho
cheese sorry apologies all right Fazbear
flon with guac cuz you're a weirdo yeah
yeah
uh-huh and hot
sauce yeah that's that's normal all
right don't
worry that
was literally that was your order what
are you talking about that was your
order is it because the last person's
drink was stuck there that somehow it
thought oh yeah I want to give that to
you even though it's that guy's fault
that I didn't even carry that
on whatever just shut up I don't know
what you want you want a
potato
there's a potato what do you want on it
nacho cheese you got it there you go
take it get out I got 9 seconds for this
I'm definitely going to make
it no worries Saron coming up okay
that's weird okay oh someone actually
got no get out of here 514
51 well you see how old that was kind of
I got to go through the whole
Rush again you tell me I got to do all
that again I got to all right you're
good you oh man you oh man you're about
to get it you're about to you're late as
usual your shift begins now you just
need to shut up all right what do you
want beans you got it you got the okay
this is off to a fantastic start a
fantastic start all right there you go
order up get out of here go get get get
out of my kitchen next person will lean
over this counter is going to get bopped
on the head harder than helpie and I
could have bopped help helpie harder I'm
just so kind in my heart
did someone just call me
slow cuz uh my fist is not going to be
very slow when it goes into your ass
that's not really a threat but take it
as one cuz trust me that's not going to
be
pleasant what pink lemonade you got it
all right and a soda roon wow you are
just super and a sour lime wow you are
just crushing it with the drinks here
there's that there's that damn it can I
can I just could I cue these up all of
these okay I'm going to give you that
and you're good go get out of here can I
can I have these ready oh that's so much
easier all right and rice you got two
Rices coming up Bam Bam Bam Bam that's
not yours get that out of here and you
have rocking
nachos that is get out to agree with
them
walk you slow pink lemonade and rice
okay can you uh shut up there's that and
corn you got it at least you have a
relatively easy order and this is also
helping a lot so if I got that then
maybe I could have just a ready tray of
all of
this who cares if it's in a container
it's still the same slop all right Glam
wraps oh I swear to God you have all
these microwave ones that is ex
extremely annoying nacho cheese on the
chips and the taco okay take it get out
of here that's what you get don't order
three meals there we go rice and corn
Baba buoy skinny Taco 5 four one one
that goes there this is here you got
guac and hot sauce coming right up there
you go get out of here who wants corn
who wants rice who wants whatever this
is is sodon oh already up on you rice
already inside you consider it
practically eating 333 baby with nacho
cheese coming right up there you go
who's the next lucky customer coming in
you want rice it better be rice oh my
God I called it rice on that Fazbear FL
coming up we got three oops it's okay 3
42 Fazbear FL right there with hot sauce
you're a freak but I like it
get out of here report
to well I was getting really good at
that once you do some prep
work makes it almost easy oh head chef
bot Thanks that'll be a welcome presence
okay head chef bot where are you at are
you in the kitchen no that would be too
logical you here
somewhere there you are oh
hey that's just weird why that is that a
prize is that a supposed to be good
pizza pizza pizza all right I guess it's
food prep day to make pizzas flatten the
dough top add toppings and then bake it
turn completed pizzas into world famous
pizzer ritos using the pizza roller
pizzeros sure whatever you say oh
hi oh oh boy this again all right
actually I'm going to I'm going to
reorient myself here hold on not
quite hold on hold on chica hold on
there we go things smells good okay yeah
that's great chica that's great okay
hold on I'm I'm just I'm barely getting
what in the
world oh my God all right we got fries
well all right I fries holy crap this is
not ideal okay fries there uh
dough blap wham wham wham put the H Faz
sauce Faz sauce on there o o well that
doesn't look healthy shredded cheese oh
oh oh my
God what are you doing in my kitchen
don't make me wait any longer I don't
think this is your
piz do you want me to starve
uh well hold on I'm I I'm I'm I I'm I'm
all over the place shredded cheese
okay shredded cheese oh wow I'm way
behind uh okay good not
meat uh not
really uh wow I'm I am not doing good
and I've
crashed
oh I hope it doesn't come back with a
big old jump scare
oh oh yeah I did the
thing all right good good okay this
feels better I can deal with
this let's get these going all them
going okay what do you want orange I can
do that but let me get you your pizza
first p p p okay we got fazer sauce it's
a little moldy don't know why I'm back
here and meat right there pop that in
the oven let's blast that out and get
you your
orange okay and who my god oh oh
oh
okay hi hi um man
the I just feel like the um standard of
food here is a little on the Lower Side
pizza sauce not
meat we got meat and and we got shredded
cheese Wham pop that in there pop that
in there oh oh we got it okay pizzarito
and Fries you got it there you are order
up finally yep
yeah
uh oh what you
mean oh did the pre did the pizzarito
fall off that's not my fault it's on the
floor go pick it up it's not like you
care go and prep a pizza I guess okay
what can I do for you pink lemonade you
got that coming up oh man this is a
complex Pizza that for me okay meat it's
not chica it's really
not that's going in there that whatever
that timer is it doesn't know what it's
talking about it really doesn't because
that is impossible to adhere to okay
there's your pizza and whoa my God get
out of here get my God put it there
there you go order
up thank you taat now it's so good to
see you what the next one oh my
God uh-huh what can I do for you and
also prepare to die I think there's that
and just fazer sauce easy peasy easy
peasy there oh you know Pizza
hi
uh-huh you like that
that that was right right okay good oh
man all right let me get my pizza going
because these orders are take a bit of
doing all right what do you got orange
pink lemonade pizzarito we got tomato
sauce regular tomato sauce meat and not
meat not for me it's not using both
hands is kind of important pizzero Style
pizzarito Style there's a pizzero ha
yeah hold on just wait patiently
there you
go ow ow what am I hitting
ow hi okay good good all right a salad
with what I'm sorry a salad with
what
with shredded cheese on Theo and fazer
sauce okay
that's oh God damn it okay hold on hold
on
bazer sauce shredded cheese it matters
what order that's in that's going in
there it's a
pizzarito mother go it's fine something
smells it's fine that's not the one I
just cooked is it is
it get it in the pizza there okay all
right here's this okay it's going to
have nacho cheese I remember that for
some reason that's strange not my
problem that's my problem shredded
cheese and meat Bam Bam there's your
salad here's your sour lime orders up
smells good it sure
does okay let's get this going oh my god
oh I thought you were about to kill me
fre Pizza Dorito we got tomato
sauce we got meat not meat me not meat
and Fred
cheese and it's a pizzero style there
pizzero style oh you no I don't know
pink lemonade and another pink lemonade
two pink lemonades coming up there's
that it's a very tight lid on that so
don't
worry yep there you go you're really
keeping us float here chica thank
you Moon Rush complete all
right oh God okay we got a pizzarito
with meat shredded cheese
and not meat smells good oh God damn it
not the salad oh freak not meat thank
you okay now all right what this is
pizzero style and then we got a pizza
with tomato I thought that went off
there real quick okay with tomato pop
that in there regular old pizza with
tomato that does make a lot of sense but
I'm not going to question it we got an
orange and of course we have another
orange because why wouldn't it be the
ones I could prep when it could be
something that I can't prep get out of
here yep I
know all right let's get a pizza
going all right what can I do for you oh
my God okay we got a pizza with nacho
cheese not meat shreddy cheese meat for
me no I mean well yeah okay I know I've
been saying no but in all honesty I I
think it's no surprise that it actually
is a yes that's got fazer sauce on it
which is super strange and also moldy
not meat there's your salad and you got
another salad with shredded cheese not
meat and nacho cheese
sauce okay that's three items and Fries
there
okay oh my
God
hi good to see you
pizza with fa sauce you got it okay meat
and shredded cheese not meat and
shredded cheese is that me got pizero
style okay two fries easy thank you and
then we got an orange oh my God don't do
that order
up oh the demands of food service nap
time okay good where
where where are you napping
oh oh oh oh I did
it
yippee I did it a message
you
what I'm wa I see a Faz R confront the
darkness use the key to confront the
water the key is familiar to
[Music]
you
uh-huh you talking about the Faz wrench
cuz I'm a little familiar with
it okay
um I
suppose uh-huh oh I remember
this oh God that's
finicky it's going to nail
it
sh oh god oh princess Quest okay
well
uh clocking out already take off your
mask um are you talking about this thing
on my head
um yeah yeah yeah um insert coin I don't
know if I have a coin do I have a coin I
don't think I have a coin where's my
coins where do those
store where do those go I had a coin I
kind of ate them all I I don't know if
I've got them like on my pocket oh is
another
prize yippee also what did I get did I
get
Glam how glammy are you oh you're not
glammy at all you're not glamy anyway DK
where you yeah I haven't seen foxy at
all but either way we got a mystery for
next episode I got to figure out a way
to get a coin into that machine so all
this can be well and I can continue on
my way because everything is kind of
virused up the only things I haven't
done yet is the
carousel I've done the food prep and
I've I haven't done the reiterations and
Bonnie bull is still there done the
makeovers everything else is virused so
I think in the next episode I'm going to
start with the Carousel and see how that
does you okay with that chica yum okay
all right thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye